And now for you, Scoutmaster.
I just spent a few moments looking at a trip report,
which is basically like a crew log from our canoe trip in 2004.
We had a day of pretty good rain,
and we decided that we were going to head out a little bit early
because we were pretty wet,
and it didn't look like the weather was going to get much better.
And so we headed down a huge lake,
8 or 10 miles of paddling down this big lake with the wind at our backs,
and it all went pretty well.
The waves were a little high,
and we were very anxious to have things over with.
And we got in sight of the dock there,
probably just about 75 yards from the dock,
and I was in the stern of our canoe,
and one of my assistant Scoutmasters,
he was in the front seat of the canoe up in the bow.
And we had turned the corner, and we saw the dock,
and we're ending this big trip for six or seven days out in the wilderness,
and we were really happy to see the Outfitters store there and everything,
and we were paddling along quite nicely,
and then my partner's canoe paddle broke,
like right in the middle.
It just broke.
It broke in half.
He couldn't do anything.
And so I paddled us in.
Seven days with that paddle.
It broke in the last 75 yards,
and we didn't have a spare along with us.
You know what we've done since?
We carried a spare paddle.
Hey, that's one useful way that these little patrol logs and trip logs work.
So we'll be talking about it a little bit more.
This is podcast number 25.
Welcome back to the Scoutmasters podcast.
This is Clark Green, and this is podcast number 25,
a day of celebration.
Okay, celebration's over.
Let's get down to business.
In Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to be talking about patrol logs and their usefulness.
And then I have a Scoutmasters minute for Scoutmasters.
Not really for Scouts, but for Scoutmasters.
And it's not a minute.
It's a lot of minutes.
But you're used to that, aren't you?
And then we'll end up with our third installment
in our discussion of building a troop-based high adventure program.
All righty, then.
I think we should get with it, don't you?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
Somewhere along the way recently, I mentioned patrol logs,
and I've gotten a couple of questions about the importance of them
and how they work and et cetera.
So I want to spend a couple of minutes just talking about
how a patrol log is a useful tool to a patrol leader
and a senior patrol leader.
What is a patrol log?
Well, basically, it's just a diary of what the patrol does,
and it contains some facts about who was participating
and what they did and things like that.
But most importantly, it should have a place for each member of the patrol
to put in their personal reflections on exactly what worked for them
and what they enjoyed
and perhaps what they didn't enjoy and what didn't work for them.
This way, the patrol leader can review it
and the senior patrol leader can review it
and they can look at improving the way that they present their program.
Practically, a patrol log is, you know, one of those little composition books
and the patrol leader has that with them
whenever his patrol meets
and the patrol scribe is the one who is charged with keeping up with the log
and making sure that things get written in it.
One of the ways that we emphasize the usefulness of the patrol log
is anytime we're camping, whether it's a weekend camp out,
whether it's a high adventure trip, or whether it's our week at summer camp,
the patrol log gets opened every evening just for a few minutes.
The patrol sits around and they make a record of what's in their log.
And then when we're on a weekend camping trip, it'll be on a Saturday night.
We usually arrive on Fridays.
And then on a Saturday night, after dinner is cleaned up,
the patrol will sit down and make a record in their log.
And then they will all get together, the entire troop will get together
for what we call Vespers,
which is just a little evening observance of a scout's reverence and duty to God.
And we use the patrol logs as a way of starting the conversation
about what went on today and what worked well and what didn't work.
And this lasts for, you know, 15 or 20 minutes,
but it gives us a way to sit down and to concentrate on what we're doing
and why we're doing it.
At summer camp, the patrol leader's council will assemble every evening for a few moments
after the patrols have made the entries in their logs.
And the patrol leaders will each share what's in the log.
And the patrol, the senior patrol leader will work with them to help correct things that are wrong
or maybe encourage them to do something that they've missed
or congratulate them on a job well done.
And it's also a way for me to sit back kind of quietly and listen
and get a good idea of exactly what's happening during the day at summer camp.
And maybe it will bring some things to mind that we need to deal with
and maybe it will give me an opportunity to give the patrols and the patrol leaders
a good pat on the back for a job well done.
It's a pretty simple system.
And it's not something that we require of the scouts.
It's not something that we force upon them and we double check
and we read all the patrol logs and we make a big deal out of it.
But it's more or less a tool that they can use and we encourage them to use it.
And we don't get all upset and angry when they don't.
But we encourage them to use it and to make a good habit out of it.
Does it work all the time?
No, absolutely not.
It doesn't work all the time.
But it does help.
Our high adventure logs probably have been the most useful to us over time
because they helped us capture a lot of little details
that have helped us improve those trips over time.
And the scouts really like going back and reading them
because we make a tradition out of, you know,
what was your favorite thing today
or what was the most interesting thing that you saw
or what was the most difficult part of your day.
And it really helps you remember after the trip is over exactly what happened.
And it has gone a long way to helping us improve the program
around our high adventure trips.
So I encourage you to give it some thought.
Get the patrol leaders and the senior patrol leader to buy into the idea
and see if a patrol log will help you in building your troop program
and building your patrols.
That's right.
It's time for a Scoutmaster's Minute.
If I say these two words to you, what do you think?
I've got some Borglund.
No, it's not Cub Scout code.
No, I'm not cursing at you in a foreign language.
Listen again.
Got some Borglund.
Yeah?
Doesn't ring a bell?
Well, maybe somewhere back in the deep recesses of your memory
that name is stored back there somewhere.
Heck of a name, isn't it?
Got some?
Yeah.
G-U-T-Z-O-N.
Got some Borglund.
Well, you might not remember the name,
but you know this guy.
You certainly do.
Now, Got some probably not a good person to use as an example of a hero
in some ways.
He had some troublesome politics in his time.
He was irascible.
He was a perfectionist.
He was difficult to get along with.
But you know some of his work.
You absolutely know some of his work.
Who is he?
Well, look.
This is why he came to mind.
The other night, we were at a scout meeting,
and we were having our little patrol leader's council afterwards,
and I was working away with the guys.
I was encouraging them and trying to coach them
and work with them a little bit.
And it was, you know,
it was like emptying a bathtub with a teaspoon.
You know exactly what I mean, right?
You think,
well, are we going to have to talk about this again?
Do we have to go over this ground one more time?
Well, you do.
And that's what Got some did.
Yeah.
You got to keep chipping away at things.
It's one little chip here,
one little chip there,
and finally you have something in the end
that you've chipped away out of the solid rock.
And this is what came to mind after,
you know,
we sat through five or ten minutes of listening,
and then I talked to the guys for a little bit
and asked them lots of questions
about what they were doing
and why they were doing it,
trying to get to the point of a resolution
and moving ahead.
And as, you know,
as we left,
one of my assistant scoutmasters
kind of looked at me
and he kind of sighed
and shook his head
and I said,
yeah, I know,
I know,
this is like trying to,
this is like trying to build Mount Rushmore.
You just keep chipping away.
You get the air hammers out every morning
and you get on a rope
and you put yourself down
and you start chipping away.
And, you know,
maybe every once in a while
you can get out the dynamite,
but probably not
because that'll blow the whole thing to pieces.
So it's just constant effort,
consistent.
Mount Rushmore took about,
I think,
you know,
closing in on 25 years.
That's who Gutzum Borglund is,
right?
He's the sculptor
who created Mount Rushmore.
But he kept chipping away,
didn't he?
And that's what we've got today
up in the Black Hills
that every single person
who's hearing me
has seen at least a picture of.
Our work sometimes
in scouting
is kind of like
building Mount Rushmore.
Yeah,
just a chip at a time.
You get rid of all the stuff
that you don't need.
You refine the stuff that you do.
And the final result
is really
kind of a work of art
and a wonder to behold.
I can imagine somewhere,
like in the 12th year,
Gutzum Borglund getting up
in one morning
and saying,
what in the world
have I gotten myself into?
But you know,
he kept a vision.
He knew in his mind
what he wanted to create.
He knew how to do it.
He kept at it.
We're creating something
as scout leaders.
We're creating an environment
for boys to grow
and to learn some things
about the world
to develop character
and to become
decent human beings.
And it works.
Sometimes it takes longer
than we think it ought to.
And it's a little bit
more difficult
and you gotta keep at it
all the time.
But in the end,
when you step back,
you'll have something
that you'll be happy
you spent the time creating.
Yeah,
just like
in Mount Rushmore.
So keep at it.
Keep chipping away.
This is the third installment
in our discussion
of how to establish
a troop-based
high adventure program.
And we're going to talk
about the skill development
and training
that is going to be necessary
to having a successful
and safe
troop-based
high adventure trip.
Now,
fortunately,
the BSA offers
a number of
excellent online courses
that will prepare you
to conduct
a safe
high adventure trip.
Weather hazards training,
trek safely,
climb on safely,
safe swim defense,
and safety afloat
are all
excellent online courses
that I recommend
highly to you.
And I would take
all of the ones
that are available online
because they all
have common elements
and it will help
build a consciousness
of safety
and of risk management
that will assist you
in making sure
that your scouts
come back
from their high adventure trip
a little worn out
and maybe a little tired
but ready to go back
and challenge things again
and that you have
a good,
safe experience
when you're out
in the wilderness.
High adventure
means,
to a certain extent,
higher risk
than we are undertaking
when we are in,
you know,
our general
troop campouts.
Because we're going
to put ourselves
in a wilderness situation,
there's a likelihood
that we're going to be
several hours
away
from any kind
of emergency
response system.
Within the past
several years,
the BSA
has begun requiring
that people
who go to Philmont
and people
who go to
the other
national high adventure
bases
have someone
in the crew
who is certified
in wilderness
first responder.
The wilderness
first responder training,
when I took it
a year ago,
it was a 16-hour course
done over the course
of two days.
It emphasized
how we could
assess injuries
and illnesses
and how we could
keep people stable
until the professional
responders were able
to get to us.
It is absolutely
invaluable
and it should be
a required component
of your training
if you're going
to conduct
a high adventure trip.
There are a lot
of unfortunate stories
out there
of people who go
into the wilderness
woefully unprepared,
unfamiliar with
their surroundings,
the situation
that they're going
to encounter
and they end up
in injury
or being lost
for several days
or some kind
of just terrible,
awful story
that you do not
want to repeat
as the leader
of a group of scouts
on a high adventure trip.
Now, this shouldn't
scare you away
from it,
but it should give you
an appreciation
of how important
it is to have
a good risk management
mindset
and to have
the skills
to manage
problems
when they arise.
Now, by the time
they're old enough
to participate
in a high adventure trip,
most scouts
should have some
pretty solid
general camping skills.
They should be familiar
with how to put up
their tents
and how to cook
and things like that,
but I would make sure
that any preparation
for a high adventure trip
emphasizes those
particular skills
that will be needed
once they are
out there
in the wilderness
and they're on
their high adventure track.
By experience,
I've learned
that you do not
want to train people
to hang bear bags
at night
in the woods
in the wilderness.
You'll want to train
them to do that
at your troop meeting place
without a whole lot
of stress
and difficulty.
So making sure
that everybody
in the crew
has a good grasp
of the skills
that are going
to be particular
to the trip,
whether it's
hanging bear bags
or purifying water
or cooking
is going to be
an important aspect
of preparation
for the trip.
So a high adventure
program need not
be expensive,
it need not be elaborate,
it need not be difficult,
it is something
that any troop
can participate in.
Whether you are
headed off
to one of the
national high adventure
bases,
whether you're doing
a council-based trip
or, as we have
been discussing,
building your own
kind of high adventure
trip,
it is definitely
worth the effort.
It need not be
expensive,
it need not be
elaborate,
but it will be
something that
your scouts
will remember
for years to come.
Now the three
installments that
we've had on the
podcast about
high adventure
are really just
an outline.
There's so much
to consider,
there's so much
to think about,
and there's so
much to do
that I would
really appreciate
any questions.
You can send
them to me
by email
and I would
be more than
happy to help
you get a
high adventure
based program
off the ground
for your trip.
Well, thanks for
listening to this
edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast.
You can read
the Scoutmaster
blog at
scoutmaster.typepad.com
You can follow us
at Scoutmaster
blog on Facebook
and Scoutmaster
CG on Twitter.
Feel free to leave
a comment when
you subscribe to
the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes.
You can leave a
review or a rating.
You can email me
Clark Green with
your comments and
questions at
clarkgreen at
gmail.com
C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
all one word
at gmail.com
Well, the
Scoutmaster blog
and the
Scoutmaster podcast
are not official
publications of
the Boy Scouts
of America
nor are they
endorsed or
sponsored by the
Boy Scouts of
America.
Nope.
It's just me here
talking into a
microphone trying to
lend a hand to
Scout leaders and
perhaps have a bit
of fun along the
way.
Hey, have a good
time at the
Jamboree.
It's coming up
soon, isn't it?
A week or two?
Yeah?
I think it'll
probably be a
fantastic experience
for folks.
And with that in
mind, let's turn to
the founder and
see if he has any
good wishes to
offer you today.
Sir Robert?
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why, thank you,
Sir Robert.
Until next time.
ils um
dipping
along open
together
and
kissed
last winter
inеб
guitar solo